Ich hab ständig diesen Ohrwurm.
# Heilpraktiker.
# Verkannt und verlacht.
# Ich bezahle dich bar,
weil's die Kasse nicht macht.
# Heilpraktiker,
kannst du mir Globuli geben?
# Ich will Kräfte wie Hulk
und für immer leben.
Nein, Freunde der Sonne,
das wird kein platter
Heilpraktiker-Verriss,
falls ihr das erhofft
oder befürchtet habt.
Das ist kein Schwarz-weiß-Thema.
Sicher ist nur:
Wir wissen zu wenig.
Man merkt an dieser Stelle,
wie wenig wir
von der Materie verstehen.
Für manche sind Heilpraktiker
wie "kleine Ärzte",
nur ohne Kittel
und mit mehr Zeit und Mitgefühl.
Für andere sind Heilpraktiker
wilde Esoteriker,
die nichts mit Medizin zu tun haben.
Aber wie die Realität aussieht,
mussten wir auch recherchieren,
und da hat mich einiges ...
überrascht.
Holt euch 'n Tee,
macht's euch gemütlich, los geht's.
(Lässige Musik)
Falls ihr gute Erfahrungen
mit Heilpraktikern habt,
könnt ihr wahrscheinlich gut
bei dieser Geschichte mitfühlen.
Ich hatte einen schweren Autounfall,
den ich nur durch irres Glück
überlebt habe.
Und hab aber
fast keine Folgen davongetragen -
jedenfalls dachte ich das.
Und hab sehr viel später
Schwindelanfälle gehabt,
bin ohnmächtig geworden.
Ich war damals
schon Medizinstudentin,
wurde von Arzt zu Arzt geschleust
und in die Uniklinik,
aber man hat halt am Herz,
an den Nieren, am Gehirn
überall nichts gefunden.
"Keine Ahnung, was du hast."
Ich war aber zunehmend verzweifelt
und bin zu 'ner Heilpraktikerin -
auf Empfehlung
von einer Kommilitonin.
Die hat gesagt:
"Mensch, ist doch ganz klar!"
"Das hängt mit der
Posttraumatischen Belastungsstörung
nach einem nahezu tödlichen Unfall
zusammen."
Und das war schon der erste Moment,
wo ich dachte:
Warum ist mir das
nicht selbst aufgefallen?
Das hat vielleicht schon
so große Erleichterung gebracht,
dass ich mich selbst
wieder verstanden habe
und das als posttraumatische Störung
zuordnen konnte.
Und dann natürlich
viel besser damit umgehen konnte.
Die hat mir Globuli gegeben
und gesagt:
"Immer, wenn das kommt,
nimmst du die."
Damit hatte ich auch
ein Tool in der Hand.
In wenigen Wochen
waren die Beschwerden weg.
Das ist Dr. Natalie Grams.
Sie ist Ärztin -
und sie war als Ärztin
auch Homöopathin.
Für mich hat das damals
wie ein Erweckungserlebnis gewirkt.
Ich dachte, wow, das ist so toll,
das muss ich lernen.
Doch inzwischen gehört sie zu den
wohl prominentesten Kritikern
der Homöopathie
und auch des Heilpraktikerberufs.
Warum sie diesen Prozess
durchlaufen hat,
werden wir im Laufe des Videos
noch erfahren.
Vorher müssen wir klären,
was Heilpraktiker genau machen.
Das ... ist ... einiges.
In dieser Umfrage
zweier Heilpraktikerverbände
waren 2017 knapp 60 Prozent
als Heilpraktiker
im Bereich Psychotherapie tätig,
der Rest im Bereich "Naturheilkunde".
Psychotherapie und Naturheilkunde
sind bereits zwei
sehr unterschiedliche Bereiche.
Und Naturheilkunde ...
kann alles sein.
Ich glaub, es war
'ne ganz typische Heilpraktikerin.
Die hat ein unglaubliches Konglomerat
von Methoden gemacht.
Sei es Schröpfen, Akupunktur,
chinesische Heilmassage.
Die hatte aber auch so Geräte
mit ... Elektromagnetresonanz -
keine Ahnung mehr -,
wo irgendwelche Schwingungen in den
Körper geleitet werden sollten.
Das war alles
nicht gegeneinander abgegrenzt.
# Auf nur einem Bein stehend
heulte ich den Mond an.
(Heulen)
# Der hat gesagt,
das sei gut gegen Migräne.
Das sind die Top Ten
im Bereich Naturheilkunde
laut der Umfrage.
Wissenschaftlich betrachtet
kriegt man da ...
(Würgelaut, Husten)
Leichten Reizhusten.
Homöopathie zum Beispiel.
In den 200 Jahren,
seit es sie gibt,
ist es trotz unzähliger Anläufe
nicht ansatzweise überzeugend
gelungen, nachzuweisen,
dass Homöopathie besser wirkt
als eine Placebo-Behandlung.
Ich finde, da kann man sich
langsam damit abfinden,
dass sie das nicht tut.
Ansonsten verweise ich
auf dieses Video,
wo wir demonstrieren,
was in Globuli wirklich drin ist.
Was haben wir noch?
"Entgiften".
"Detox" heißt das auf Instagram.
Ist auch mehr Fantasie
als Wissenschaft.
Also, für echtes "Detox"
braucht man nur zwei Sachen:
eine gesunde Leber
und gesunde Nieren.
Über Akupunktur müssten wir mal
ein eigenes Video machen,
alles andere würde dem Thema
nicht gerecht werden.
Es sei gesagt:
Es ist wissenschaftlich umstritten.
Anderes ist vage formuliert:
Schmerztherapie,
Ernährungstherapie,
Gesundheits-
und Präventionsberatung.
Sodass man die Wissenschaftlichkeit
nicht pauschal bewerten kann.
Halten wir fest:
Wissenschaftliche Fundiertheit
steht hier nicht unbedingt
an erster Stelle.
Das heißt wohlgemerkt nicht,
dass alle Heilpraktiker
von allen wissenschaftlichen Geistern
verlassen sind.
Wer Heilpraktiker ist,
macht nicht automatisch Schwurbel.
Genauso wie eine Ärztin nicht auto-
matisch wissenschaftlich arbeitet.
Es gibt ja auch Ärzte,
die Homöopathie anwenden.
Um als Heilpraktiker tätig zu sein,
braucht man keine Approbation,
also keine staatliche Zulassung,
wie sie Ärzte, Zahnärzte,
Psychotherapeuten vorweisen müssen.
Und bei Psychotherapeuten
ist das verwirrend,
denn während
den meisten klar ist,
dass Heilpraktiker keine Ärzte sind,
ist der Unterschied zwischen einem
psychologischen Psychotherapeuten
und einem heilpraktischen
Psychotherapeuten
den meisten Laien
nicht besonders klar.
Um als Heilpraktiker
arbeiten zu dürfen,
braucht man
eine Heilpraktiker-Erlaubnis.
Dafür muss man eine Prüfung
beim Gesundheitsamt ablegen.
Wie sieht diese Prüfung aus?
Laut dieser Infobroschüre
des Verbandes
deutscher Heilpraktiker
"sehr schwierig".
(Schmunzeln)
Das macht mich eher misstrauisch,
als dass es mich überzeugt.
Schauen wir uns das mal genauer an.
Es gibt einen schriftlichen,
einen mündlichen Teil.
Der schriftliche besteht
aus 60 Multiple-Choice-Fragen,
von denen 45
richtig beantwortet werden müssen.
Da werden
Krankheitsbilder abgefragt.
Im mündlichen Teil findet man zum
Beispiel hier Gedächtnisprotokolle,
es gibt Fragen zu Gesetzeskunde,
verschiedenen Krankheiten
und Fallbeispiele, wo erfragt wird,
wie der Patient behandelt wird.
Vieles scheint vernünftig.
Allerdings fallen diese Prüfungen
von Gesundheitsamt zu Gesundheitsamt
sehr unterschiedlich aus.
Es gibt keinen geregelten
Prüfungsstandard.
Da das zuständige Gesundheitsamt
vom Wohnsitz abhängt,
findet man in Facebook-Gruppen
immer wieder den Tipp,
einen Wohnsitz oder Praxisraum
anderswo anzumelden oder Ähnliches,
um die Prüfung dort zu machen.
Nach bestandener Prüfung darf man
aber deutschlandweit arbeiten.
Ist diese Prüfung also ...
"sehr schwierig"?
Darüber streiten sich Heilpraktiker-
befürworter und -gegner gerne.
Worüber man wohl
nicht streiten muss, ist,
dass man mit
60 Multiple-Choice-Fragen
und einer mündlichen Prüfung
nur so viel abfragen kann, klar.
Das ist aber eigentlich
gar nicht der springende Punkt.
Wenn ich das vergleiche
mit meinem Chemiestudium:
Da bestand die Diplomprüfung
auch nur
aus vier mündlichen Prüfungen
à 60 Minuten.
Ja, ich bin alt.
Ich hatte Diplom.
Was mich viel mehr interessiert, ist:
Was passiert vor der Prüfung?
Was muss ich vorweisen,
um die Prüfung ablegen zu dürfen?
In meinem Fall waren das zum Beispiel
acht Semester Chemiestudium
mit etlichen Klausuren,
Prüfungen, Laborpraktika,
die man bestehen musste -
ne, Scheine sammeln.
Was passiert also
vor der Heilpraktikerprüfung?
Welche Ausbildung gibt es?
Tja, Freunde der Sonne,
genau hier liegt der Hase begraben.
Der Hund begra- ...
Der Hase im Pfeffer.
Ihr wisst schon, was ich mein.
Um zur Heilpraktikerprüfung
zugelassen zu werden,
muss ich an Ausbildung lediglich
einen Hauptschulabschluss vorweisen.
Mehr nicht.
Ähm ...
Sagt mal, gibt es noch irgendeinen
Beruf im Gesundheitswesen -
Krankenpflege,
Rettungsdienst, Geburtshilfe -,
wo man keine fachliche und praktische
Ausbildung vorweisen muss?
Ohne eine fachliche Ausbildung
kann die Heilpraktikerprüfung
keine fachliche Eignung überprüfen -
egal, wie schwer sie ist.
Und das sag nicht ich,
das ist offiziell.
Deswegen ist sie genau genommen,
also formal,
auch keine Prüfung,
sondern nur eine Überprüfung.
Ähm ...
Ich weiß nicht,
wie ihr das seht,
aber wenn ich krank bin
und deswegen zu jemandem gehe,
hab ich etwas höhere Ansprüche,
als dass er mir nur nicht schadet.
Noch mal, weil's so wichtig ist:
Laut Heilpraktikergesetz
dürfen Heilpraktiker
die Feststellung,
Heilung oder Linderung
von Krankheiten, Leiden
oder Körperschäden durchführen.
Voraussetzung dafür ist
die bestandene Heilpraktikerprüfung.
Also ... -überprüfung.
Nur stellt diese Überprüfung
gar nicht sicher,
dass man Krankheiten feststellen,
heilen und lindern kann, sondern:
Wie kann es sein, dass eine Prüfung
nur so viel abfragt,
man danach aber so viel machen darf?
Ich will natürlich nicht behaupten,
dass Heilpraktiker automatisch
schlecht ausgebildet sind.
Es gibt viele, die zum Beispiel
eine therapeutische Ausbildung haben
und dann die Heilpraktikerprüfung
oben draufsetzen.
Oder: Es gibt auch
Heilpraktikerschulen,
die Ausbildungen anbieten.
Laut dieser Broschüre
wird vor der Prüfung
im Schnitt eine dreijährige
Ausbildung absolviert.
Nur: Sie ist halt nicht
gesetzlich vorgeschrieben.
Es gibt zwar Prüfungsleitlinien
oder auch
solche Fortbildungszertifikate,
aber nichts davon ist verbindlich
oder wird kontrolliert.
Das ist doch auch nicht
im Sinne der Heilpraktiker.
Ich hab mit dem Studienleiter
einer Heilpraktikerschule gesprochen,
der erzählt hat, wie sie schulintern
die Qualität sicherstellen,
dass er sich aber auch verbindliche
Standards für alle wünscht.
Und dass er es gut fände,
wenn man zum Beispiel
Scheine sammeln müsste,
um zur Prüfung zugelassen zu werden.
Das heißt,
eine Qualitätssicherung
ist nicht nur
im Interesse der Patienten,
sondern auch
im Interesse aller Heilpraktiker,
die ihren Beruf ernst nehmen.
Also ... seh ich das richtig,
dass ...
alles dafür-
und nichts dagegenspricht,
dass Heilpraktiker nicht nur
diese Überprüfung vorweisen müssen,
die ja nur sicherstellt,
dass man keine Gefahr ist,
sondern eine gescheite
fachliche Ausbildung?
Da sind wir uns einig, oder?
Es gibt zwar
eine Berufsordnung für Heilpraktiker.
Darin wird
aus dem Urteil des BGH zitiert:
Doch Verstöße gegen die Berufsordnung
haben nicht etwa dieselben
Konsequenzen wie bei Ärzten.
Verstöße können bestraft werden ...
Man kann auch aus dem Verband
ausgeschlossen werden,
was einen aber nicht daran hindert,
den Beruf weiter auszuüben.
Auch hier ist also alles
wieder nur unverbindlich.
Gut, nächster Punkt.
Wenn Heilpraktiker
zumindest dazu ausgebildet sind,
keine gesundheitlichen Schäden
anzurichten,
dann gilt ja für den Gang
zum Heilpraktiker das Motto:
Oder?
Heilpraktiker
dürfen manche Tätigkeiten
ausdrücklich nicht ausüben.
Sie dürfen zum Beispiel
keine Geburtshilfe leisten,
keine Infektionskrankheiten
behandeln,
generell keine meldepflichtigen
Krankheiten - wie COVID-19.
Doch alles,
was nicht explizit verboten ist,
ist erlaubt.
So darf ein Heilpraktiker
zum Beispiel Krebsleiden behandeln,
während ein Hausarzt
einen Krebspatienten
zum Onkologen weiterleiten würde,
was einfach nur ...
Also ... im negativen Sinne.
Nun geht's mich ja nichts an,
wenn ein krebskranker Mensch
neben seiner Behandlung
zum Heilpraktiker geht
und sich Bachblüten geben lässt
oder wenn jemand bewusst
eine medizinische Behandlung ablehnt,
zum Beispiel eine Chemotherapie.
Hier soll nicht die Freiheit
infrage gestellt werden,
über seinen Körper zu entscheiden.
Nur: Gefährlich wird es,
wenn man eine medizinische Behandlung
in dem falschen Glauben ablehnt,
dass "alternative Heilmittel"
besser wirken.
Wie zum Beispiel
bei dieser 18-Jährigen.
Sie bekam bösartigen Knochenkrebs.
Behandelt wurde sie mit
"Geistheilung" und: Homöopathie.
Keine wirksamen Medikamente,
nicht einmal Schmerzmittel.
Und dieser Krebs
ist sehr schmerzhaft.
Drei Jahre später starb sie.
Abgemagert.
Metastasen in Leber und Lunge.
Eine konventionelle Behandlung
ist bei dieser Krebsart
mit über 70-prozentiger
Wahrscheinlichkeit erfolgreich
und hätte ihr zumindest
schlimme Qualen erspart.
Es geht noch krasser.
2016 verabreichte ein Heilpraktiker
in einem Krebszentrum am Niederrhein
drei Krebspatienten den expe-
rimentellen Wirkstoff Bromopyruvat.
Ein Stoff, der zwar
im Labor Hoffnung geweckt hatte,
aber noch nicht
als Medikament zugelassen war.
Als wär das nicht hart genug,
wurde das Präparat
vom Heilpraktiker selbst gemischt,
obwohl er noch einmal
eine ausreichend sensible Waage
dafür hatte.
Sodass er den drei Patienten
eine Überdosis verabreichte
und sie so tötete.
Es gibt natürlich auch in der Medizin
schreckliche und tödliche Unfälle.
Und Fehler.
Und fahrlässige Tötungen.
Es macht nur für mich
schon einen Unterschied,
ob jetzt zum Beispiel
ein Chirurg bei einem
riskanten Eingriff versagt
oder eine Ärztin bei einer
komplizierten Behandlung
eine falsche Entscheidung trifft -
oder ob der Fehler ganz klar
auf fehlende Ausbildung
und Fachkompetenz zurückzuführen ist.
Wohlgemerkt ist dieser
Bromopyruvat-Fall
ein dramatischer Einzelfall.
Der nicht repräsentativ für die
Heilpraktikerbranche stehen sollte.
Um Gottes willen.
Und inzwischen
wurde das Gesetz verschärft,
und solche Behandlungen
sind erlaubnispflichtig.
Was mir aber zu denken gibt, ist,
dass diese drei Patienten
der Behandlung mit diesem
experimentellen Wirkstoff
zugestimmt haben.
Und ich frage mich einfach,
angesichts der schockierenden
Fahrlässigkeit des Heilpraktikers,
ob diese Patienten wirklich
angemessen informiert
und aufgeklärt waren.
Wir alle wollen als Patienten
gut behandelt werden.
Was ist eigentlich
eine gute Behandlung?
Wir Ärzte haben zum Beispiel
unsere Leitlinien,
da wird gesagt,
was State of the Art ist,
wie man diese und jene Erkrankung
wissenschaftlich gesehen
am besten behandelt.
Abweichungen davon
muss man gut begründen können.
Vor sich selbst, vor dem Patienten -
und im Zweifel vorm Staatsanwalt.
Das gibt's bei Heilpraktikern
überhaupt nicht.
Es gibt noch nicht mal ein Maß,
an dem eine gute Behandlung
gemessen werden kann.
Und das hängt natürlich
damit zusammen,
dass bei Heilpraktikern
nichtwissenschaftliche Methoden
sehr gängig sind.
Wenn Methoden gar nicht erst
auf Wissenschaft basieren,
gibt es natürlich
keine evidenzbasierte Leitlinie.
Und deswegen, find ich,
ist sehr wichtig,
zwischen wissenschaftlichen und
nichtwissenschaftlichen Methoden
klar zu unterscheiden.
Ich möchte auch gar nicht,
dass nichtwissenschaftliche Methoden
verboten werden.
Was ich möchte,
ist Transparenz.
Das, was ich tue,
ist Aufklärung.
Es wird oft wahrgenommen als Bashing,
als Hetze, als Gemeinheit.
Das, was mir ein Anliegen ist,
ist die gute Behandlung
von Patientinnen und Patienten.
Darüber möcht ich Klarheit schaffen,
sodass man weiß,
worauf man sich einlässt,
wenn man zum Beispiel
Homöopathie nutzen möchte
oder zum Heilpraktiker
oder zur Heilpraktikerin geht.
Ich möchte das niemandem verbieten -
ich möcht's erklären.
Weil ich glaube, dass man,
wenn man alle Fakten hat,
auch tatsächlich -
und nur dann -
eine freie Entscheidung
dafür oder dagegen treffen kann.
Es gibt gute Gründe,
sich für eine Heilpraktikerbehandlung
zu entscheiden.
Zeit. Zuhören. Zugewandtheit.
Das ist alles Mangelware
im medizinischen Alltag.
Ein ausführliches Gespräch
mit dem Patienten
kann bereits Medizin sein.
Die Ergebnisse aus der Forschung
legen nahe,
dass Zeit für den Patienten,
die sogenannte "Sprechende Medizin",
kein, ich sag mal,
"Wohlfühlextra" ist,
sondern tatsächlich messbar
die Behandlung
und die Wirkung der Medikamente
beeinflussen und verbessern kann.
Dank Placeboeffekt.
Ärzte beschweren sich selbst oft,
dass ihr Honorierungssystem
ihnen nicht genug Zeit
für die Patienten lässt.
Letztlich war das ja
auch meine Motivation damals,
zum Heilpraktiker zu gehen.
Ich hab mich einfach
nicht gesehen gefühlt.
Und ich glaube, in dem Bereich
kann man sehr viel mehr leisten.
Wir sprechen immer von "Humanmedizin"
und lassen das Menschliche weg -
das ist superschade.
Kein Arzt konnte Natalie
von ihren Beschwerden befreien.
Der Erfolg kam erst nach ihrer
Erfahrung mit der Heilpraktikerin.
Was sie letztlich gemacht hat,
war vielleicht
gute Gesprächstherapie,
wofür sie gar nicht ausgebildet war.
Sie war wohl menschlich
einfach schwer in Ordnung,
aber hatte in ihrem Rüstkasten
keine Therapien oder Maßnahmen,
die das auf gute Weise -
oder wissenschaftlich gute Weise -
begleitet hätten.
Das ist schade.
Wie kann man das jetzt lösen?
Wie gesagt: höhere Anforderungen
an die Ausbildung
und strengere Qualitätskontrollen
einerseits.
Aber wie kann man
einen sinnvollen Weg finden,
nichtwissenschaftliche Methoden
zu erlauben,
ohne dass die Gefahr besteht,
dass Patienten sie
als "medizinisch" missverstehen.
Ich stell mir immer so vor,
dass man so eine Art Umschulung
zu einem "Genesungspraktiker"
vollziehen könnte.
Vor allem auch dann,
wenn bekannt ist,
dass es vielen guttut
und menschlich hilft,
wenn sie zum Heilpraktiker gehen.
Und, ja, dann müssten sozusagen
Heilpraktiker aber
von ihrem Anspruch, kurativ,
also heilend, tätig zu sein,
ablassen.
Aber sie könnten ja
stattdessen wohltuend
im Sinne der Palliation,
der Linderung von Symptomen,
tätig sein.
Und dann können sie
von mir aus auch gerne
Aromaöle geben
und Klangschalenmassagen machen.
Sie kommen dann
der wissenschaftlichen Medizin
gar nicht mehr in die Quere.
Heilpraktiker
wollen das auch gar nicht.
Zumindest laut
Bund der deutschen Heilpraktiker.
Auf den dramatischen
Bromopyruvat-Fall
reagierte der Bund etwa so:
Und auch hier argumentiert der Bund,
dass Heilpraktiker eben
keine Alternative zur Medizin sind,
sondern medizinische Therapien
begleiten können
"oder sich um Menschen kümmern,
die als austherapiert gelten".
Und zu all dem
kann ich nur sagen:
Ja. Genau.
Und dann hat mich an der Recherche
am meisten überrascht,
dass sich beide Seiten
an diesem Kernpunkt
anscheinend ziemlich einig sind.
Nämlich, dass Heilpraktiker
als begleitend und lindernd
tätig sein sollten
und nicht als ersetzend.
Die Frage ist jetzt nur,
welche Regeln es braucht,
damit das in der Praxis auch
verantwortungsvoll und korrekt
umgesetzt wird.
Was meint ihr?
Was für Regeln oder Gesetze
wären wichtig,
damit Menschen
sicher und transparent
von auch nichtwissenschaftlichen,
aber wohltuenden Methoden
profitieren können?
Und habt ihr Erfahrungen
mit Heilpraktikern?
Wenn ja, teilt sie gerne.
Wenn nein: Wärt ihr vielleicht
eher dazu bereit,
einen Genesungspraktiker aufzusuchen
statt einen Heilpraktiker?
Ich bin gespannt
auf eure Kommentare.
Schaut noch mal
unten in die Videobeschreibung.
Da verlinke ich euch Natalies Podcast
"Grams' Sprechstunde".
"Der Podcast für Recht gute Medizin".
Wo sie die erstaunlich spannende
Schnittstelle Medizin - Jura erklärt.
Es gibt auch eine interessante Folge
über das Heilpraktikergesetz.
In der End Card
verlinke ich euch unser Video
"Fünf Missverständnisse
zum Placeboeffekt".
Der wird ständig sowohl unter-
als auch überschätzt.
Und ich verlinke euch ein Video
von " Terra X Lesch & Co".
Harald Lesch hat nämlich
eine sehr coole neue Kollegin,
nämlich die Astrophysikerin
und angehende Astronautin
Dr. Suzanna Randall.
Sie erklärt euch,
wie man Astronautin wird.
Schaut gerne vorbei
und hinterlasst 'n paar Kekse.
Wir sehen uns in zwei Wochen.
Bleibt sicher.